the jurogan experience i think exercise
is the single most important longevity
drug we have bar none like if you
if you were if you said like i want to
go deep down the rabbit hole of living
longer what do i need to do
it's it's like a super well-crafted
exercise program that is geared towards
strength muscle mass and cardio
respiratory fitness so it's all the
above it's not just one right so i mean
the hazard ratios for each of these are
pretty interesting we've this has become
like
each year i try to bring one new focus
into our practice
and
the past 12 months the focus has been
entirely around taking exercise to a new
level in terms of our understanding of
how to fine-tune it and the data are
unbelievable right so if you
everybody knows that if you smoke or
have diabetes your risk of death goes up
a lot
but
your risk of death
from having high cardiorespiratory
fitness goes down by much more than your
risk of death goes up from smoking your
diabetes
so smoking and diabetes will double or
triple your risk of death depending on
the time frame you're looking at
having very high respiratory fitness so
having a vo2 max that is elite we would
define that as the top 2.5 percent of
the population compared to below average
is a five-fold reduction in all-cause
mortality death from any kind whoa
i mean
there we don't have drugs that have a 5x
reduction in mortality
that's incredible and that's just
elite cardiovascular health right and
then when you layer in strength and
muscle mass
we actually now have pretty good data as
to the fact that strength is more
important than muscle mass we just use
muscle mass is a good proxy for strength
but if you just focus on strength that's
the metric that matters it's about a
three-fold reduction in all-cause
mortality when you compare high strength
to low strength
and the tests are you know we're talking
it's not like how much you can squat and
deadlift it's like grip strength dead
hang
how long can you do like an air squat
you know like what's your quad strength
how quickly can you do five reps up and
down from a chair i mean it's relatively
simple stuff but when you stratify
people by those metrics and you compare
the highest to the lowest performers
there's just no comparison is there a
point of diminishing returns though
where you just get really really strong
but it's not helping you any more than
being
fairly strong on the strength data we
don't see it because the data have only
been parsed out as high to low on the
cardio respiratory there is a point of
diminishing return so remember i said
elite is the top 2.5 percent and then
you so it's it's it's it's um we break
them into five categories but they're
not equal in bucket size you get most of
the benefit honestly by going from not
fit at all to average fit that gives you
three of the 5x
now that said
you know i hold myself and my patients
to a way higher standard which is we
have a chart that shows all the data by
age by gender and by vo2 max
and i would say if you know if you're a
52 year old male
i'm asking you to have the vo2 max of an
elite 42 year old male so i want you to
be a decade younger elite and then we do
the same thing with strength metrics
and when you prescribe that like say if
you take a a 52 year old male that
doesn't have a history of cardiovascular
activity you know maybe they you know
lightly work out the gym or something
like that what what particular exercises
do you think are the best to achieve
that result so we start with a base of
zone two so this zone two is that
lactate thing i was talking about so
your zone two is defined as the highest
level of aerobic output that you can
generate while keeping lactate below two
millimole so i think a bike is the
easiest way to do this because the
stationary or stationary just because
it's you can keep it steady state you
know when you're on the road it's all
you're all over the place but um so if
you're on like a you know a stationary
bike
and um so huge and also wattage is such
an easy metric for people to understand
so how many watts are you putting out
right so um the first thing we would do
is say you probably need to be doing at
least three hours a week of that zone
two which is building an aerobic base so
four 45-minute sessions at zone two
constantly driving it up and honestly
one session of vo2 max training per week
and the best protocol for that is the
4x4 protocol so that's four minutes at
the highest output you can sustain so
here you could do it on an air bike or
something right so you could do what's
the highest wattage you can hold for
four minutes and then four minute
recovery
and do five of those sets once a week
so when you're doing that do you think
that the best is like an air dyne that
works the arms and the legs or do you
think just a regular bike that just
works the legs like what is
for zone two i mean it really just
matters that you're consistent but um i
think most people find you can do a
higher output when you're on an air bike
in terms of absolute wattage because you
are leveraging upper and lower body it
really doesn't matter that much i mean
you can do this on a treadmill you can
do this on a stair climber you can do
this on any kind of cardiovascular
activity but you need 45 minutes four
times a week that would that seems to be
the minimum effective dose on zone two
now if someone's super deconditioned it
can probably be three 30-minute sessions
to start and they'll see benefit
interesting and then as far as a
strength program like do you recommend
specific exercises is it like squat
deadlift well it depends on this is
where it gets very dependent on the
person so we have a test that we put our
patients through that's um 10 exercises
and they're all basically normalized to
your body weight and gender so like a
dead hang so how long
can you hang from a bar dead so for me
should you be able to hold we hold males
to the standard of two minutes and
females yeah and females to a minute and
a half at the age of 40 so then it gets
discounted by decade watch the entire
episode for free only on spotify